hey guys Pete here mr. robot season 4 is
officially underway this will be my
recap and review of episode 1 which is
titled unauthorized if you haven't
watched it this will definitely contain
spoilers about everything we saw in
episode 1 and speculation about where
mr. robots for season which is its final
season is heading there were a lot of
things that jumped out as being unique
to this season which I'll point out as
we go the big thing for me though was it
feels like the end in a series that's
always presented new mysteries that
every turn this episode was the first
one that truly felt like we were headed
towards definitive answers the
previously on segment the recap that
gets us set up for what we need for
where things left off it blends right
into the first scene here and it's a
doozy it's an end in and of itself the
end of Angela's character we pick up
right where we left off in the season 3
finale with her talking to her
biological father Phillip price they're
talking about White Rose we learned that
price is actually trying to talk her
down he's trying to get her to move on
except that she's been conned taken in
stride go back and try to lead a life
that doesn't involve fighting back
against White Rose she doesn't mention
that she's seen white roses project but
that ends up feeling unimportant and
what really sold this sequence for me
were the performances those of us who've
been following everything closely all
the preseason clips and reading the
articles that came out ahead of time
pretty much figured out this is
ultimately where Angela's story would
end and to be honest I didn't love the
idea when it started to feel inevitable
both Portia Doubleday and Michael
Christopher delivered a scene that makes
it work the Angela moment that stood out
for me was when she sees her
executioner's off screen she knows what
will happen she accepts her situation
and it hits in a way that I hadn't
guessed it might when contemplating her
dying so early in the season for price
it's as he's walking away he starts off
stumbling and then we watched his rage
build as he walks off he rips off the
wire there's a nice sound effect here
with the glitch and the sound as he
pulls it and we learned that he's
complicit whether he was trying to
protect his daughter or not it all
underlines the idea that White Rose is
pretty much unstoppable
that carries
where we see him grieving in the next
scene and when like I said it's not an
ideal ending for her but it is a great
looking scene I like the way they put it
together
rip Angela you'll be missed we get white
roses introduction to season four as she
calls price they talked on the phone
after they talked we learned that
there's a holdup Elliot's solutions
gonna take two months before they can
get the shipping to the Congo White Rose
tells her assistant that she wants to
send a reminder to him to let him know
what's at stake we see later in a quick
flash that it's a picture of Angela's
dead body and then we get our jump in
time as the camera zooms past White Rose
we see coming to New York at
Christmastime the camerawork looks
slightly different in season four
there's still plenty that gives it his
signature look but they've added some
tricks to their bag as far as I can tell
I really liked the opening credits look
with the out-of-focus bits there and
thought this whole opening few minutes
looked pretty fantastic we end up in a
lawyer's office at a Christmas party we
get introduced to a new character who
has a pretty short run as far as things
are concerned Freddy Lomax he gets a
package and while this is a really fun
scene to watch and it's a reminder of
how good Elliot is at doing what he does
I don't think we need to talk about it
too much in the recap other than we see
that Elliot's driven he's focused he's
trying to take down White Rose he's got
this guy who's a lawyer he gets his
inbox he finds out where white roses
banking is done we also see that because
he gets this name that there's more
going on well yeah it's really focused
and taking care of business and he lays
this plan really well until Lomax kills
himself the fact that he gave him a name
that turns out to be a honeypot later on
shows that it's not like Elliot's flying
completely under the radar
obviously the dark army was following
him there and yeah we get the idea
there's a lot going on behind the scenes
on both sides and we don't know what's
going on with Elliot because he won't
tell us we get a couple quick glimpses
of other characters and where they're at
after the season three finale tyrell is
basically a hero at this point
we had a shot in the taxi ride over
showing that the economy has bounced
back everybody's excited about that
Tyrell being the CTO of a corpse and a
good spot he looks like he's not really
having that much fun taking on that life
though his existence looks a bit
meaningless perhaps compared to what he
thought he was doing before we see Dom
looking really paranoid and beat up at
her mom's place we could see that she's
been drinking we go to the all safe
building which looks like that is the
new arcade if you will and we see that F
Society is basically now just Elliott
although he's working hand in hand with
mr. robot we saw this really well in the
Grand Central scene and we just see it
throughout this episode they're working
together they're not at odds at allsafe
we see that mr. robots at the computer
he's going through the social media
accounts of this John Garson character
Elliott's got his own private conspiracy
string board kind of thing going on with
post-it notes on the office windows we
realized that Elliott is in a hurry
because there's not that much time mr.
robot is the voice of reason here he
warns him that he's making it too
personal he's acting out of anger and
Elliott gives us a pretty good monologue
about how people are forgetting how
they're exhausted he's exhausted -
Darlene comes in she's obviously using
drugs she's out of her mind
she believes she saw Angela Elliot knows
this is not possible so he doesn't
really want to deal with Darlene he's
seen the photos of Angela's dead body
and as viewers we get mr. robot coming
and talking to us which he doesn't
usually do he tells us that Elliot is
shutting us out he's basically shutting
everyone out and we can see that that
dynamic of Elliot being the voice of
reason that that has basically flipped
Elliot decides to go to garson's office
he's going to deliver a package that's
going to get him access to the Wi-Fi
there when they get there it's obviously
set up
it's a honeypot he doesn't figure this
out until it's too late as viewers we
get the idea a little bit faster because
it's obviously set up nobody's there
they're looking around it doesn't look
like anybody's ever really work
there mr. robot says in the hall as
they're approaching that this is the
quietest building in Manhattan
I like the quirkiness here the man at
the counter eating fruity pebbles we
have another character talking loud they
like facetiming someone on the phone a
different language that we can't
understand and after Elliot gets himself
caught we hear the guy at the counter
fire up don't worry be happy' on his
iPod in that place through the halls it
continues playing as Elliott is dragged
away by two men and he's kicking and
shouting as they go back out in New
Jersey we meet the new character Janice
at Dom's place her mom thinks she's
invited Janice over to possibly set her
up with DOM but we learned that Janice
is actually the one pulling the strings
here she comes off as nerdy and harmless
at dinner then does this 180 and reveals
her true colors when they're all alone
outside Janice tells Dom that she's
gonna have to wake up in the morning and
go do the interview about the Santiago
case because that mess needs to be
cleaned up she promises that she's gonna
have to do something very bad to her
mother if it's not taken care of Dom
tries to threaten Janice but it's made
clear that if she does something to her
then someone else is just gonna step up
and take her place after she makes that
clear Janice leaves and Dom's reality is
exactly what we thought it would be at
the end of last season we get one more
look at Darlene how she's trying to
medicate herself through the pain of
losing Angela she's staying in Angela's
apartment getting loaded and we see her
throw everyone out and then collapse
onto the bed crying with Angela's ballet
shoes back at his apartment Elliot is
actually being held down by those guys
who kidnapped him as they tie a
tourniquet around his arm we see a third
man prepare a lethal dose of heroin to
inject in him the man preparing the shot
is actually showrunner Sam I smell doing
a cameo he's had small cameos in
previous season but here he plays a
pretty substantial part when Elliot
employers for him to say something he
just says goodbye friend before he gives
him the hot shot I wondered if the drug
scene might be related to a forced
overdose in my trailer breakdown for
season four and that turned out to be
the case only I never thought that
Elliot would actually die after
struggling and then seeing a vision of
his family that include
his mom and himself as a kid he does
indeed overdose and go out though the
screen fades to black and the credits
start but I mean of course this isn't
the end of Eliot's story it's the
opening episode of the end of the series
and in a Power Move s Mel's character
revives our hero with narcan he inhales
of the deep breath and he springs back
to life we find out that these guys work
for Phillip price who accompany ism back
inside the room and that's a pretty
mysterious part of this episode I said
it's a Power Move killing someone just
to bring them back to life sends a
message we can get to you and we can
take you out the mystery at least for me
is what price is actually up to we have
to imagine that he's trying to put a
squad together to go up against White
Rose in the dark army rather than
delivering this as a message for her
that would seem to align his goals with
Elliot so why would he go through such
great lengths to get in touch with him I
guess we'll have to wait and see what
price has up his sleeves since
technically he's still under white roses
thumb and it isn't clear here if he's
the one who fed the name Garson or if
White Rose would have been the one to do
that
there was a lot to like in this episode
and the table is certainly said the
show's always been great looking and I
really like the way they sort of
expanded things here it felt like there
were a lot of interesting panning shots
some handheld stuffs that really added
tension in different ways that I'm used
to watching mr. robot and Elliot working
together was a nice change of pace it
made the Grand Central scene work really
well and it sort of cracked me up won
mr. robot took over so seamlessly when
Elliot was talking to Darlene and he was
just done with it we can clearly see
that Elliot's in a different headspace
Freddie Lomax is nobody in the grand
scheme of things but his whole sequence
was important I mean it served as more
than just an opportunity to call back to
the opening of the series where Elliot
hacks and turns in a pedophile
Elliot plays a role in this man's death
and it barely makes him pause to
consider the implications of what he's
doing he's on a mission to take down
White Rose and in his words he's done
with the therapy sessions things are
dire and there is a literal timer on his
light we also have a little bit of humor
in here as well especially with Janice I
like the stuff with Dom's
a little back and forth some macaroni
and gravy but there was also the flatter
stuff they slipped in there at Angela's
whenever Darlene's there so it wasn't
completely a hundred percent dark I like
Janice the character and I like the way
they introduced her how well she played
the part of an unassuming dark army
enforcer there's a lot of potential
there obvious parallels to Irving's
character who we haven't heard any word
of to this point we have to imagine the
DOM and Darlene are gonna come back
around they're gonna get themselves
straightened out somewhat over the next
couple episodes because time is of the
essence with time counting down we have
to imagine a lot of these are gonna be
like episodes that are gonna be short
windows of time this should be really
the only time jump that we get to me
this whole idea of Elliott only being
useful until the project moves and that
in turn being an expiration date for him
makes a lot of sense in bringing the
story to a conclusion in a sense it
doesn't matter what white roses project
does anymore because Elliott's gonna be
eliminated if it makes it to the Congo
of course Elliot is a point he doesn't
care what it does he still wants to take
out White Rose no matter what and one of
them has to go down I thought this made
it feel like a nice simplification and
it was effective and nullifying a lot of
the far-out and sci-fi theories I mean
people have them people are gonna
continue to have them people are going
to guess that Angela isn't really dead
and that something different happened
rather than what we saw happen to Elliot
with the overdose but overall things got
more focused and simplified in the
stakes and what Elliot is trying to
accomplish with the five nine hack he
found out that the top 1% of the 1% was
the best suited to retain their power
and even profit off of the misery that
everybody else experienced in that
situation mr. robot pointed this out to
him he said this used to be about
changing the world now you're trying to
get back and yeah I'm sure that this is
gonna take some twists and turns but it
all ends in a showdown between white
rose and Elliot think white roses
project is going to be like something
for leverage to try to get Elliot to
change sides but I don't think that the
weight of it all is necessarily what's
gonna make the end of this interesting
we'll have to wait and see though I did
look around a little bit
after the episode before I started
working on this and I saw people or
jumping to sci-fi theories which that
happens every time and people have some
good ideas but I didn't get that vibe
from this at all that's not where my
head went but let me know what you guys
think in the comments would you think
about the first episode it was strong
I enjoyed it the fact that it's a
table-setting episode takes away a
little bit like it doesn't put it up in
the top of the top episodes of all time
but it did its job and there was
definitely some crazy moments the same s
male cameo was fun I hope we get to see
a lot of him actually in the rest of
this season I'm really curious as to
what price we'll get up to how that will
play out how long Elliott's gonna keep
us shut out what's gonna bring him back
around and yeah let me know what you
guys think in the comments let me know
what questions you have about what
happened in episode 1 season 4 what
theories you have about the season going
forward please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already I'll be
doing episode recaps throughout the
season
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon